I was 19 years old when a few friends
and I walked out onto the streets of Los
Angeles and handed out our first meal
fast-forward to today and we've served
1.3 million meals my name is Rachel
sumac you can call for that thank you my
name is Rachel sumac and I'm the
co-founder and CEO of a start-up
nonprofit called swipe out hunger and we
allow college students to donate the
extra money from their meal plan to
hungry people in their community
particularly other college students how
many of you went to a public elementary
middle or high school
all right go public schools I imagine
that you also remember those huge
cafeterias where you would go in there's
a long line you're waiting you're
picking up the things that you want and
as you approach the lunch lady
some students handed money and some
students handed in la a little yellow
lunch ticket and in cities like New York
70% of students are eligible for free
lunch
so many that they just passed a law
making just free lunch and breakfast for
everyone great stuff I'm in the city
like Los Angeles it's 50% of students
and I remember being a kindergartener as
one of those students standing the lunch
I'm a little yellow ticket clenched in
my hand ready to get my lunch my parents
were immigrants they're Persian Jews
Iranian Jews and they were just started
to get their stride in Los Angeles we're
still hustling to make it happen and I
was very lucky that by the time I
started fourth grade they had made it
they were accomplishing the American
dream and we were living a pretty good
life but I think at the moment that they
really thought I had accomplished the
American dream was when their daughter
got accepted to UCLA and you think go
Bruins UCLA and most colleges don't have
large cafeterias like public schools but
we do have amazing dining halls and meal
plans and for anyone who might remember
buying that 10-15-20 meal week plan and
having extra
left over on your plan by the end of the
week which you didn't use would roll
over and roll over by the end of the
semester I maybe you guys can relate to
this you had hundreds of dollars left
over you weren't sure what to do with it
my friends and I found ourselves in the
same predicament we said that there must
be something better that we can do with
this we decided to get a little table
set up outside the dining hall and ask
our friends and ourselves to go inside
and buy to go boxes of food bring it out
to us which we would then go and hand
out to people on the street has this
mountain of white styrofoam boxes behind
this by the end of the day is pretty
incredible
and the first thing UCLA administrator
had to say to us was get this the hell
off campus as you can imagine they
weren't the biggest fans of a bunch of
college students walking into the dining
hall buying this food they didn't expect
to have to prep and having this flow
dozens of students going in and out but
rather than either disobey them or lay
down we thought that we had a valid
claim here so we decided to do a little
bit of community organizing
we got campus administrators involved we
got a couple student body president of
the SU by president student government
involved and after a couple months of
negotiation got them to agree to a new
model now students were able to approach
a table outside the dining hall at the
end of the semester and say I want to
journey my hundred extra points those
funds are taken from their account and
used to help help end hunger in the
community was very exciting slowly we
started to get attention from other
schools you see at USC down the street
UC Santa Barbara or you began to grow by
2013 we had received more attention than
we can handle more interest was coming
in we decided we needed to hire someone
full-time and because this is a female
empowerment you know I'm happy but like
a female focus event it would be a shame
if I didn't share at least one of the
many daily microaggressions I have to
face and this one was actually something
that helped shift us push us forward it
was when a break called one of my
co-founders and I said he's a couple
years older than me he said hey I know
we're trying to hire someone and you
know what if I stepped into this role as
CEO and his response was
I'd really thought about that you know I
think you're just too nice to be a
leader and I took it really personally
because I saw myself as capable and in
my mind being nice never conflicted with
leadership so what I did instead was get
a mentor put together a business plan
build a budget put together a Job
Description move back to Los Angeles in
September 2013 walk into a Starbucks
open my laptop and stop my first day as
a full-time executive director so I've
got hunger a couple months couple months
after that day about a little less than
a year year later I remember sitting now
in a cool co-working space looking
across from an excel sheet saying that
we have collected hundreds and hundreds
of thousands of dollars just by looking
at meal plans and thinking to myself
that's amazing I know these dollars are
probably doing something really good in
the world but I'm not sure like what
like where are they what's going on and
I started to ask myself what if we
actually channelled these funds towards
something specific something measurable
something we knew would make a
difference and that's when the
opportunity and almost a responsibility
to tackle a specific segment of hunger
became clear and that was to focus on
college student hunger the same
kindergarten to 12 you 12th grade
student who hustled their way through
school is now in college still hungry
has a diet and the first thing you do
you wants your budget is tight is to cut
your food and if you ask me I don't
think ramen noodles is enough to keep
someone going consistently and able to
be successful in class so I felt hunger
began to channel these funds from one
students meal plan on to another
starting in 2012 2002 today and now
students are able to walk into the
dining hall and have an amazing warm
meal just like everyone else but I'm not
here to share our founding story with
you actually here to share the story of
a phone call I received in March of this
year it was a phone call from the
legislative aid of a local Assemblywoman
and she asked me you know we've been
thinking about the issue of college
student hunger it's pretty prevalent in
California and across the country one in
four students at UCLA and UC Berkeley
regularly skipped meals because of lack
of access to funds
and her office this Assemblywoman wanted
to take this on as her issue she used to
be a professor at UC Santa Barbara and
saw how the impact of hunger the impact
hunger had on her student's academic
performance
she asked me if we were to pass a law
that would scale your program statewide
what would you want it to say and I
literally started bawling and lifted my
jaw off before I like pitch the idea are
to and does everyone know what this seat
assembly is this is California we just
like the federal government there's a
Senate and the House of Representatives
in California we have a Senate and in
assembly so a couple weeks later I get
an email back from them with a proposal
on official state letterhead the
watermark with the words that I said
being proposed as a bill for the state
of California fortunately there are
amazing amazing policy wonky people who
helped make it actually effective and it
and look nice and then a few weeks later
I gave the most important pitch of my
life which was a two-minute pitch to the
Senate the assembly higher ed committee
in Sacramento begging them asking them
inspiring them to adopt this piece of
legislation and a couple weeks ago we
were now months in June we were sitting
in our office and we were keeping an eye
on the bill and made it past assembly
was getting through the Senate before
made it through the Senate Governor
Brown plucked it up put it into his
budget and with the bill said was any
university at 144 public community
colleges state schools and you sees if
they implement this bill which said if
you have our program or a food pantry
and also someone on campus who helps
people sign up for CalFresh for food
stamps then you'll be able to get some
of this funding and we had originally
thought a campus would get a couple
thousand dollars
Governor Brown created a 7.5 million
dollar fund based off of the program a
couple of 20-somethings started based
off legislation a 25 year old bro and
now the state of California is finally
taking seriously the impact that lacking
basic needs has on its college students
and just as a reminder a few years ago I
was being told get this the hell off my
campus and a few years after that I was
being told I'm not capable of doing this
that I'm too nice and after that I was
told this is such a nice volunteer
project but when are you gonna leave and
go to law school you know you went to a
good school you can do something real
with your life and as I think about what
lessons or things I want to look back on
and share there's two that really come
to mind the first is that innovation
does not come from an app that saves you
two minutes in the morning even those
are great and I use them true innovation
is whenever you reexamine the resources
and systems around you and see them in
new ways and you ask how do I make this
better how do I change this system a
resource to help impact someone else's
live life and those are things that we
can take steps towards tomorrow and the
other thing I want to share is sometimes
you have an idea and you're notched or
if it's the right thing the way to solve
that is by just doing it and being open
to feedback and responses and asking
yourself how do I make this better every
single day but continuing to be
committed to it while also being open to
what's possible because you never know
you might end up swiping out hunger
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
you